what's up everybody my name is clinton
jones and i am the punisher
today i am excited to announce
the next community render challenge
last year i challenge you all to create
your very best render
from a simple bare bones animation that
i provided to you guys
nvidia and pny sent me an nvidia rtx
quadro 6000 to show off its insane
performance
and over the following month i live
streamed the creation of my most
ambitious
render to date 125 artists submitted
their renders and five of you guys
won some top tier prizes thanks to
nvidia and pny
now enough people have asked for another
render challenge and guys today i'm here
to deliver and happy to announce the
alternate realities community render
challenge
where i'm challenging you guys to use
the animation provided
to create the coolest render you can
possibly create
and over the next month i'm going to be
live streaming the process
of my 3d animation and at the end
combining everything together to make
the most epic 3d montage the world has
ever seen
and if you're on the fence let me just
start with the prizes i reached out to
some of my favorite companies
to build a prize pool full of products
that i not only love but use every
single day to create the art that i love
creating we're talking rococo wacom
pny aftershocks and quixl
so without further ado i give you guys
the community
challenge prize pool starting with
fourth and fifth place
you actually get two things first is a
one year subscription to the qixel mega
scans
library it's my absolute favorite
one-stop shop
for the largest collection of high
quality 3d scans
materials and even metahumans i use mega
scans for every single project
and i hope to get you guys hooked too
and on behalf of pny
fourth and fifth place also get a pny
two terabyte two and a half
inch sata solid state drive for quick
read and write speeds
of all your files and programs now i
know a lot of you guys aren't from the
united states we have a big
international audience and keeping the
prizes
open to my international audience is a
big deal for me
so if any of these companies can't ship
to your area for whatever reason
they'll ship them to me and i'll ship
them to you myself
now if your render comes in third place
you're gonna get a wacom
intuos pro tablet and wacom is so cool
that they're gonna let you choose either
a small medium or large size
tablet i personally use the medium but
you guys might like the large size you
might like the small
i love these tablets because they save
your wrist
which you're gonna jack up if you use a
mouse too often also there's a ton of
different buttons and hotkeys on this
thing so you guys can work super
efficiently i literally hadn't owned a
mouse
since i got one of these things and i'm
never going back we all we're not even
halfway through
with the third place prizes because pny
is swooping in
again to get you all a one terabyte m2
pcie
gen 4 ssd the read and write speeds on
this thing
are ludicrous and finally third place
also gets the year-long subscription to
the quixote mega scans library
that's right guys these prizes yeah they
stack
now if your render comes in second place
out of who knows how many submissions i
will receive
you're lucky to not only get the wacom
intuos pro tablet
the pny one terabyte m2 pcie
gen 4 ssd the one year long quixote mega
scan subscription but
also a pair of my favorite
aeropex open ear headphones by
aftershocks i freaking love these things
i use them to listen to music and
podcasts
all the time when i'm going on walks
when i'm working when i'm
filming basically anytime anywhere and
the kicker is that you can still hear
your surroundings with these things they
don't go in your ear they kind of go by
your temple and they vibrate the bones
in your head
and music is a big inspiration for me
when it comes to my renders so i'm
hoping that these can help you guys out
as much
as they've helped me and if your render
is the best render
out of all the renders then you will
receive
the qixel mega scans one year
subscription the wacom intuos pro tablet
the pny one terabyte m2 pcie ssd
the aeropex open ear headphones by
aftershocks
and the grand prize a full performance
capture
bundle from rococo complete with the
smartsuit pro
smart gloves and a year-long
subscription to their studio plus
software
including the facial capture with
rococo's full performance capture bundle
you guys will be able to capture your
body data
your hand and finger data and your
facial data
to tell more unique stories you'll never
have to hand animate this stuff ever
again
and i actually use rococo's smartsuit
pro to record the animation data for
this
challenge their software allows you to
loop the animation data too which is
perfect for this content
because i want each submission to
seamlessly flow into the next when
combined together for the internet's
largest render montage
so what makes a winning render in my
mind well
probably uh render quality attention to
detail
overall composition use of color and
lighting
and probably uniqueness judging this
contest is not going to be easy because
there's going to be a ton of submissions
so to keep things fair and unbiased i'm
going to recruit two guest judges
for this challenge that i will announce
a little bit closer to the submission
date of june
1st june 1st is the deadline to submit
your render
so as a resource for you guys over the
course of this month during the render
challenge
myself and the discord mods have set up
a series of channels on my discord
server
to answer frequently asked questions a
place where you can show your renders
in a place where you can get advice on
your works in progress so if you're
looking to push yourself and create an
incredible piece of art
over the next month then click the link
in the description
to get started inside our project files
for
every modern 3d program in a video
called watch me first
it goes over the details of how to set
up your render and how to deliver
your submission again by june 1st if you
guys don't know how to get started then
start with this video here where i
create concept art
based off an idea i see in my head to
kind of give me a look and feel
in a direction for the render that i
want to create
but guys i can't wait to see what we
make together let's get to it
download the link in the description
june 1st is the deadline
and i'll see you guys next week in the
live stream where i'll be working on my
piece of art
alongside you guys see you soon peace
[Music]
you